I don't know care if he [ __ ] packs
let him get farm I hope he cries I'm
about to meet you my my own bit about to
mute you hey guys is what we is what we
always wanted unreal to shut up and not
to hear him
so please [ __ ] kids now and they'll
take a joke like your vomits hey Coco
he's in here
who's in here who's in here oh I thought
I was going that is my bad but laying
hot ass cracks Jesus just sing the whole
time in like all our plays that'd be fun
oh yeah we will
how did we do it oh [ __ ] I just clear
flanking on the left flank in almost
like [ __ ] unreal he seems he pretty
uptight I really don't care if he
[ __ ] packs let him get far I hope he
cries so we got a whole team huh we got
a to5 it's gonna be it's gonna be metal
Monday before so it's gonna be a [ __ ]
I can do no no that would be amazing
dude
that would be amazing out which I'll
torture oh dude this guy's messaging me
I think it's the the other team guys
should I open it or no open it I want to
know what it says open it and ask him if
they're it see if they're asking you for
playing death metal well he said I want
to play Star Wars what what he asked me
if I wanna play Star Wars
his name is heavy metal or e1 too heavy
yeah we got time-traveling what's going
on he's like [ __ ] Matthew McConaughey
and ourselves
Lincoln darn our feed boner seems he was
just watching us from another dimension
II to do a feed he's probably your
slaves in Terminator your son goes back
in time to [ __ ] kill the Terminator
to save his daddy 2029 it's the year 29
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got you [ __ ] with John Connor you're
probably a goner Hey
I mean the guy bites terminators so I
mean I'm just being [ __ ] with John
Connor are you probably a goner
especially the Christian Bale one cuz he
actually fought the [ __ ] terminators
man yeah
be demo gonna rap to see we're gonna
wrap all the way around in 2029 is a
year of junk honor
oh that guy just [ __ ] hold a cracker
and shoulder guarding to me I'm coming
out smaller where they at
there's still one more outside I'm
coming to you to be bi mát B I got to
her out dude I'm just getting peace the
[ __ ] up yo I need help let C just come
around me get it on rail I'm gonna grab
a there's an oval oh there's a DBMS wave
very low guy yeah I got him
no I got him
[Music]
what is happening with this man Wow
it's the worst Matthew brown swing it's
the worst Matt but I'm just like I'm
getting absolutely hammered
oh they got Oh
sniper rifle Oh shitty slight me real
good push it push it real good real good
you don't take don't take it don't take
that deca ball
Pisa mock dick all over oh oh they're
all weak it's yeah my grenade hit the
hell out of them oh man all right
they're gone move question is this a
team yeah pretty much it is dude yeah
pretty much gotta see my mom oh my god
yeah they're really good good
they're holding hands dude they're the
[ __ ] holding hands over there Jesus
oh my god they're sniping that hype so
be careful
one guy's down
one guy's pushing he's dead there's an
art staff yeah it out see [ __ ] you're
going to see I'm going to see get some
eyes on it if you can if there's a
dollar yet nice I spun to this that [ __ ]
yo and I got that guy Goldie oh yeah
where's ya
what cups I got him there we go it's
just us Harry
all right got both I got three na I'm
taking B so we can keep C and B it's
gonna be hard to keep CA put a tripmine
on that that hit him nice
alright we got B where's that storm
coming up from mid got him [ __ ] dead
oh they know Dom sheets I'm going to see
they Nova bombed it I'm coming I'm
coming
now we're in it my friend
that's my oh come on this is competitive
dude yeah let's get it we can get this
side your story that's getting God I got
two with that Bey I got two with that
one sleeper side uh he's gonna rock it
oh he missed
so there's a guy coming around to see
he's so low I'm going to see we got the
got him there we go I got three on P I'm
gonna need help with thee I'm here
trying to flank
okay we got the heavy sleeper yeah
oh yeah Oh
sniper at sea sniper at sea madam both
let's go he's hurt
I got we need a or she [ __ ] you see this
guy was crimson dough on it
look out damn man look how he's going
through the door I mean you can god this
is ridiculous
I spawned and died what does this
provide you spawn and why does the game
hates me oh there they are
take a take a keep B I'm gonna check out
it got a month be got a mop be Ark oh
right now artifact he's coming to be
yeah he's coming to be [ __ ] toast
he's [ __ ] a tawny known as the John
Connor
we're doing good we got a good little
lead now let's just take it home he
meant stiff that rocket hey
and a gopher go deep behind us yeah I
know okay
I'm waiting for him I'm grabbin see yo
therapy
it's storm it's Dan and mobile they're
coming yeah boy shut down the storm
right when you probably popped it you
shut it down that was beautiful
[ __ ] [ __ ] unreal yeah
he's hurt dead
nice Heather nice they don't know 2491
you want to get a to just to rub it in
let's just do it got a winner I went on
a nice little streak there at the end
yeah I at the end we all stand yeah we
mess it wrong all around that was just
good it was good good [ __ ] dad 3.38 huh
mm-hmm
is it the suite business giving them two
beers
what are you using air called let me
just inspect you we'll go ahead and take
a look-see
yeah you got the tire before you use
behave I'm using know why you do this
but to winning in canons always do this
it's not to is do bliss that's something
new I've never seen yeah yeah yeah that
is beautiful beautiful yeah it's my
opinion yes it shoots so fast so fast
where'd you get that where'd you get
that going
the service from over you got to get 40
ranks in the vanguard so you gotta get
those far those [ __ ] tokens oh my god
someone in my test says what is it Steve
streaming what my streams not good
enough [ __ ] what now [ __ ] he's in my
space you can you can [ __ ] hear John
Connor 2029 is the year of John Connor
ah these guys are funny burning lots of
coming back to the future remember why
with the DeLorean
it makes them more that will put a live
back to the future with all the other
[ __ ]
full throttle what John Connor John
Connor okay so what do you think we can
uh so is this do we get like points for
winning like consecutive matches in a
row or is that just through competitive
nah that's just through quick play and
competitive iron banner yeah that's
what's crazy no great tonight huh he was
up for like two minutes
oh yeah right he said he was like I
gotta lay down let me lay down baby
that's the story of crazy he came home
and he said what up guys it in than two
seconds he said I gotta lay down you
ugly laid down and he's probably
sleeping [ __ ] you
[Music]
Steve's gonna have dreams a fight not a
[ __ ] single every 129 daddy we're
gonna be ready I already know yeah wait
I'm going completely off the grid we
gotta fight the singularity yeah yeah we
gotta oh dude it's coming guys yeah must
knows it's coming
I'm going off you're gonna be the best
suited to fight man because I know
cyborgs are gonna kill all of us yeah
that's right man I'm gonna join I'm
gonna join the cyborg technology to
fight for good that's what I'm gonna do
oh you're gonna really yeah because you
know what's more dangerous than a
[ __ ] erich koch a site work eric code
that's the most dangerous thing possibly
[ __ ] imagine
oh no you guys these guys are good
[ __ ] these guys careful they [ __ ]
suck take this oh [ __ ] like it or not
I'll [ __ ] them so hard they're gonna
have a lot of snot coming out their nose
you [ __ ] hope it's not nose [ __ ]
that's not known as [ __ ]
you better V again to [ __ ] wow dude I
want to hurt in the middle [ __ ]
ridiculous
[ __ ] I read that you see yeah there's
like that is too in the middle sit on
down you [ __ ] play on that is yours
okay what are we going up now we're just
gonna hold these two dad yep
that guy's dead yep [ __ ] down he's hurt
yup just like that baby
you know the one going far side now
coming to you and real no turned around
he's dead what is he shot Steve yep
oh my god these [ __ ] oh my
goodness
see oh my god where you guys that where
you guys have you guys that a I'm at it
right now I'm flanking all right there
were even my bluff here I gotta get out
I'm going to eight there's nobody there
oh no there's a guy up there and he had
that yeah that yeah I'm coming
small-diameter I could use hello
he's up there he got me smoke a beans in
the trap be-beez in the trap
bbbbb peepees good [ __ ] small I was
holding it down I'm coming oh I'm Gucci
now oh no I got one more coming for my
left
got one middle left yeah I missed some
rocket middle
I'm just holding this be yo I'm gonna be
I got this you got this right
I'm kidding please help me yeah I'm
kidding no but seriously tell me they're
gonna run around to a three of them
blank into a novel to that to
there's three yep I have I have three MB
I'm eating three honey alpha oh [ __ ]
now there's so much no no no long
wait what was that were they were those
guys that were they that were that
they're later you see got ones popping
up got to walk straight out of bed above
in school you should know damn look at
what's gone dude I'm melting
[ __ ] and they don't have a
chance
oh [ __ ] rocket there are they envy be
him
my dad going to be
oh what the
Oh prospector Gabi's absolute and killed
by the cross 50 oh wow what smell I'm
good help ya
- up top warlocks dead yep another one
comes with left I'm thinking yeah I'm
watch on that right okay yep
yeah I see him a guy from behind there's
a guy sniping on the other staff
oh you got about a body both of us oh my
god yep sucks
Qi AK second all the key okay that's
what I think you're graviton Lancie
[ __ ] good kill push you to be
grab this now be back here there's three
hi Bob with you I'm right behind you -
yep let's go to a I'm yeah Emily I'm
good oh it's [ __ ] pray and he took a
[ __ ] nap he's crew Juve and made it
ready to [ __ ] go oh yeah
Craig's uh we're playing some game you
know record I'm recording you [ __ ]
cake yeah we've been laying down hit
[ __ ] tracks and our producer Craig
afros isn't on like what's that how's it
going Jimmy killing it killing it
channels playing I am man look at this
[ __ ] 26 kills you got let's get Craig
this [ __ ] game probably gonna take us
down cuz in lodz that's okay we've got
team camaraderie I sent you an invite
sent you an invite or maybe I just
laughs I didn't mean to do it but is
that
greg's being pretty quiet what's going
now
Craig I don't want to sing Craig wants
to sing hey we got to get 129 the humans
and the terminators yeah we've been
crushing it single we've been killing it
singing yeah it can be anything is
randomness 2029 just say something we're
gonna all die we're going into gameplay
right now do I have to sing something no
no Craig I hope I don't
Ivana I mean checking something online
I'm trying to do something here probably
be the worst what coming from the guy
[ __ ] Russia
it's Craig's fault he hates his own
voice and that's just what I say I don't
blame him cuz Craig's voice is pretty
terrible oh [ __ ] they're flankin one
down yep it's like four at be like no
one went to be accepted me and sore nose
where did that guy come from I've got a
sling of that back heavy
I got a sleeper I'm going around back
thank you
all right me and graviton [ __ ] trade us
it's the funnest on the mountaintop cuz
you could see like different passageways
so guy on a mountaintop I'm just saying
like you know being on top of that
mountain you can see a bunch of
different I like I like ice cave because
it's it's uh it's a narrowing now
there's so many they're gonna see no
secret hole back I'm gonna push up
forget she got one one coming from the
side I'm gonna flank them for you
I got him he's dead there's another one
coming up I got him
another one there he's got a graviton
terrible oh he got me I should have
peeked that that's stupid
they're all coming this way don't do
that
you almost made me spit on my - dude Oh
No okay I'm about to get flanked by sadi
Oh No
why do we have B yes control that have
you he's got sniper I got I got shots on
there's three of them there's a bunch of
them at B bro I'm going to see you're
going to see come to see with me I don't
want to see as well
I'm coming one here with you I'm less
small hold up hey Co Co Co now Ark soul
there you go that's it okay now I'm or
year ago Stevie oh [ __ ] he got me he's
hiding behind the corner good job I got
him good [ __ ] I heard all that's what we
need to do play the buddy game
he's graviton E he's a graviton Ying
Lancer got him good help
dude you're [ __ ] killing me right
here
here this is serious malice witness
we're gonna win Steve you said it
yourself
he then shame the song and that's on
Craig that would be on Craig he will
take it to the grave
he was I'm happy I took out tonight
super low-key we're okay but if we do
lose it all god damn it I got to say
every time watched when I get that he's
that good cheap shot see what happened
Thanks I hope your pen we got being a
lot there's a guy Titan in here with a
shotgun you put up that shield he's
going to the left yet no b.push there's
a warlock five o'clock there's three of
them over there
while gonna get a we gotta push be
together yeah [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] dude
I just don't understand this
are you kidding I'm not coming to see
I'm dodging the Sentinelese chasing me
buck sent home to Joe Miller's [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're all on V guys why is no one
on V dog a I died I was no they're
coming to see to to see I'm getting
murdered just get in there behind you
lost this one now he lost 100% no one's
pushing B I was on V for about a minute
clouds a good good man that should have
killed him mono voice through a random
hammer it didn't even
it wasn't even intended for me and it
just hit me [ __ ] that I was trying to
get B what's gonna happen
a whole [ __ ] you [ __ ] sit down listen
to be have you even got B once no got it
no I got it for like [ __ ] fall I need
to listen to some sad music now month on
mad world about Craig will you sing the
song now it does it spit inside of you
the whole time the song that's and then
I'm one of my voice 20:29 just since the
era John Connor that's right it's Chris
[ __ ] police it's monotone and it's
depressing as hell I think Craig just
have [ __ ] stroke apparently he came
for words together wait what am I saying
that's a normal guy
Kirby no you kiss your daddy there's a
Griffin in them
40/29 is easy but I know but I will tell
you this yeah if we get Griffin in here
he'll sing I guarantee it oh don't think
he'll give in on it oh yeah we'll see oh
yeah see he will do oh yeah
I feel nobody's talking on the track
they don't even want to talk to you he's
a fighter
come on we got people said you got we
got we got ten fireworks at from like
1:30 in the morning and you know that's
that's good for not publishing it I
think that the tracks are catching on
dude it's the [ __ ] yes the tracks the
tracks that you're hating on but you
piece of [ __ ] you say it on the track
get hit with the [ __ ] round pounds
the race
Craig what is wrong with you okay
usually more talkative what's going on
the full fledge roundhouse to your face
I'm a song you better brace Oh what the
[ __ ] is wrong wrong you're just no fun
listen I'm waking up to work up a copy
it smell just a coffee that's what we
should do Steve is delivery coffee you
imagine how how much that would kill
what delivery coffee
ya know imagine we did billions now
Starbucks is a No
why don't you ask me again though but I
might have a different answer
oh I thought someone I thought Starbucks
dude stuff no Starbucks okay check out
two pulse rifles will that work or no
can I have the vigilance I got the
vigilance as Stevie tried escalation yet
Steve have you tried escalation protocol
yet I don't even know how to do that so
no Uriel's beat me from that range are
you [ __ ] kidding me
it's it on around there's somebody oh
he's outside
okay that's fine flank this base oh
watch others guide ingredient right
outside that door it's coming to be he's
got main ingredient what's up with the
Bones Brigade did Steve and Craig fine
Jon bones Jones in their backyard what
if it was time John what if it's John
Connor becomes
yeah I got one up there another one
coming to feed they're all coming to be
always hurt Stevie's hurt push them got
him there we go you know where the dream
team Steve or the [ __ ] dream maybe
they're at B or taken a we're taking a
na that's all I'll say
okay can a that's all we gotta say 2029
is he you all right there on a hey
Tibbie take B nope there's a guy there
with a sniper yep you gotta push that
mom back let's go guys let's go together
huh
all right don't go that way
they're hardscoping push the other way
now since their hearts going so hard yep
just like that fellas got heavy ones
push them behind us
you gotta get this home
grabbing a come on be I'm honey
[ __ ] there's another dude there watch
out does that see he's on see ya got me
got aim be going too heavy I got my
super all right now you did good you did
good there's three a day I just got
three you see and I got heavy grab see
ya yep and you got some more users email
yeah defend me does that be there I come
and see the promise [ __ ]
that kind of see inside they want this
damn thing okay there recently another
one outside and real gross
slam Batum bring them to be I oh how did
it go through them my sleeper went
through bro
he's chasing me Craig I'm behind you
I just dodged all of them that's awesome
alright I might be good [ __ ] hype
alright there we go that's tree down
hammers and a star they got him cameras
video cameras day you know all right I
killed that yeah okay up to the right to
the right a bunch of options three of
them yeah they're all that all of them
go where there you go no the pushing
beat
that's cheese down there all their nerve
they're all skill than heavy Wow man
what the [ __ ] all scope and heavy golden
gun I don't know where that's at Naomi
between a and B coming to be he's out
kinda see he's hurt got a flag on see
he's not behind me alright that be
they'll be getting heavy weights Mel
don't push it guests
now I was [ __ ] there's three there
we're not [ __ ] wrist got we're
locking tight we can take it
sniper sir
the battlefield is yours there's [ __ ]
sniper
he's so [ __ ] hurt there you go right
it's to their code no why am I so good
at this game guys why why am I so good
is this is all the dream new this is all
a dream but I'm Carolann 15 a whole
[ __ ] team
didn't to the visitant a curious on
being look at it yeah I'm done I'm too
tired
crazy almost you almost thought you
didn't really what I said thank you
I think it's your strength Steve you
give me strength
yeah
total ste its [ __ ] broken its a broke
man don't you have it sometime during
the no to your app go to terror don't
think Steve our let's go where's Griffin
yell at you know why don't you have oh
my god Craig you got a lot better that
gun make it dude I'm telling you man you
know illustrate gun is must be really
good maybe I'll take you
everything Craig Bellamy had on taking
me is that it's mine it's mine now I own
you Christ shut up thinking about going
home you [ __ ] broken Broken Arrow was
trying to convince me today that it
wasn't broken
yeah arrow I love arrow and he's right
sometimes but there he just speaks
blasphemy sometimes the big splatter
your Eddie [ __ ] my arrows is mine
sometimes man but that's okay he's not
wrong and saying that the gun is [ __ ]
not broken but you know what I'm still
trying to say that prometheus lens was
was broken yes it was but graviton it's
[ __ ] broken are you sure you're happy
raise your because there's a crutch they
don't want to be you don't want to use
it's considered it's considered cheap
all I'm saying is I do do you understand
I'm a destiny you know what I should
have done it destiny one I should have
listened to you what you try to talk me
into it I'm like nag did I'm used to my
mind and look at me now I'm kidding
[Music]
like the palindrome I remember I had one
in the vault I would never use I had
like a really good palindrome yes
okay so Craig how do I get this and go
to my ball you go to your collection yes
you're coming yeah it's not SunShot oh
no I don't have to buy it I don't have
it you uh heart no you have gotta have
another character with it
no he's gotten it Steve Prometheus lens
is that it prometheus lens rattle and so
did that go to the go to the collections
I don't have it no I don't have you're
not I do yeah when I say I'm like a
goddamn destiny God I made sure before
other people even know their own hey you
guys well do something for fun let's go
all of us versus Eric oh oh [ __ ] I'll
do it I'll do it if you want not if not
only you guys I mean if you guys all
lose to me unless you guys Q's Rumble as
your playlist then they're really hood
loose let's do let's say who's in art
who's in our team right now wait don't
leave it's it's let's just keep doing
let's just keep doing this I don't want
to bite my own words you're the best
you're the best
yeah let's just keep playing iron banner
I just want to stop going to see what
the big deal is
so this is it it's just uh second shot
in burst us high damage anyway target to
spawn void projectiles that target oh it
attracts targets when you kill like
remember the outbreak prime Steve yeah
that like you'd kill a dude and they'd
have like lasers like it's kind of like
that it's like a void version of that
except you don't need a precision kill
any kill what you can delete these
[ __ ] that shaders without having to
like I'll modem what the shaders you
know you have to get them in your dowry
no you don't have to get them in your
postmaster you can delete them from your
postmaster Oh Kenya oh yeah
where have you been Craig what the [ __ ]
man
no he's saying Craig be smoking them
crack rocks
Craig that's why we don't have you
saying that's why he doesn't want the
same that's what happens it just play
just Pierce's my ears and go straight to
my brain and I feel like it might kill
it could kill a person like nails on a
[ __ ] yeah
Frank's voice is [ __ ] nice thank you
he's got a good voice Craig's speak okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
do to get what are you doing the
operatic [ __ ] do it again no it's
probably the worst thing
[Music]
[Music]
can't one stop and I never said I was
gonna say anything too tired for it to
turn for what to move [ __ ] language
sticks yeah joystick that's not about
hold left try it you can sit here and
listen to Craig's nonsense but you can't
twiddle some joysticks it's nothing
there's nothing to filter just buy it
it just completely kills the vibe it
just it murder
it just merge I kind of like it
I kind of like it if you heard the real
song you wouldn't like it is it no if I
can't do anything with this gravity'
that means I'm not good right now just
aim for her oh you'll do everything yeah
you'll be fine
another one hurt he's hurt others brave
it just sit there today
he's not oh I can't kill some with two
shots daddy and that would be me
graviton Lance oh there's a guy where
the [ __ ] was that guy
she is deadly again Arabi there are bees
I got him off
you got it off I got him again
I got another kill hey that's pretty
hundreds that be going to a oh my god
nice be a
shut up until their dusty
[ __ ] just to go but guys got a thing
coming to be got a thing coming to the
grenade lunch art early he's got things
coming tubby oh my god is it a penis
he's got a big ol dick I'll come in to
be there were such a bunch of there we
go
he's not even our party thought they
taking a yeah and this is gonna be a
power play off me that too oh my [ __ ]
Christ
Thanks [ __ ] Lord yeah unreal
[ __ ] hobo oh there's rocket yep there
you go Steve that's what we [ __ ] yeah
it's not the gun it's me guys oh I
thought out there hang on dude I'm not
good either
oh he's the King King he's the king
are you kidding me
[ __ ] laughs aw Oh Rockets season he's
about to get some more
you got another [ __ ] rocket
I took B but they're all there they're
all I'll be there just rollin as a
threesome no no boob um oh wow it's two
girls [ __ ]
I told open the right - I'm taking okay
good
see yes I was what the [ __ ] it did a
good flank there I gotta be honest this
heavy
yeah AC it's crispy dad this heavy come
on V get B yeah I'm with you
Montez nice Firebolt
defending a nice hole Craig yeah Craig
slam em up bro
yeah walk through it yet oh [ __ ] I
walked out I did not see him head
glitching that heart oh my god
yo this for their yeah their head
pushing like crazy - they got Rockets
all the way in the back
nice they're on be delicious tasty
there's always in a second one here we
go powerful [ __ ] took over they're all
on a yeah oh I got some pricey I got
surprising they're always depressed yeah
there is a suppressor grenades in tasty
double-team yo they're moving to see how
that kind of daughter'd [ __ ] kidding
me
going outside
goddamn yeah hey be small i'm back to my
regular combo [ __ ] it
what's your right to a novel capture no
crimson no bro residence why the [ __ ] am
i getting [ __ ] no but by this guy
every [ __ ] time with that [ __ ]
slow she knows a deal I guess he knows
I'm the [ __ ] rock out with my [ __ ]
out
oh he's weak nice grand out of this yep
and they're just hardscoping down this
pod and we had a [ __ ] somebody gets that
heavy
you're gonna come D for sure they're
coming to be cray yep oh you're right
Boldin I mean hammers about cameras of
beat come as Steve I just need one one
kill
oh my my speed my hammers oh my god take
it don't take it I'm not used to the way
of fires no you gotta get used to it
yeah I feel like I'm shooting like a
pellet gun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]